Este vídeo ha sido una petición expresa
de todos los miembros de la comunidad de Patreon.
Así que estáis particularmente dedicados
a todos vosotros.
Una vez más: Muchas gracias, un millón de
gracias, por apoyar este proyecto.
Y para los que no seáis miembros de Patreon
y queráis más información os dejamos un
link en la descripción.
Arranquemos.
[Un vasto continente repleto de riquezas y
una población en rápida expansión.
El último continente en sumarse a la modernidad.
Una tierra de oportunidades infinitas.
Un territorio en el que la República Popular
China ha depositado su atención y sobre el
que ha volcado su capital: ahora el dinero
y las empresas chinas fluyen abiertamente
por este continente.
Algo que está generando muchas preocupaciones
en Occidente.]
Queridos amigos, amigas de VisualPolitik,
durante las últimas décadas el panorama
económico y social de África comenzó a
cambiar.
De la desesperación se pasó a un optimismo
casi total, un optimismo feroz e irrefrenable.
Desde el año 2000 al 2018 la pobreza extrema
se redujo más de un 30%, la esperanza media
de vida creció en más de 10 años y la mortalidad
infantil se redujo a la mitad.
Además, algunas economías comenzaron a experimentar
una evolución tan rápida que se hicieron
con su propia etiqueta: los leones africanos.
De repente, el último continente, el continente
olvidado estaba comenzando a despegar.
Así que, ¿cómo no contagiarse de ilusión
cuándo por fin, POR FIN, África estaba lista
para comenzar la carrera por la modernidad?
Sin embargo, un momento, porque la pandemia
del Sars-cornavirus-2 ha supuesto un duro
golpe.
Y no me refiero solo al impacto sanitario.
(En medio de tanta euforia, los proyectos
de inversión comenzaron a crecer como setas
en todo el continente.
Claro que la inversión hay que financiarla;
Pero como África estaba creciendo eso ya
no era un problema.
Todo lo contrario.
Con los tipos de intereses por los suelos
en los países desarrollados muchos organismos
y entidades de todo el mundo empezaron a canalizar
más y más flujos de capital hacia África,
lo que hizo que en pocos años se duplicara
la deuda externa del continente.)
No era un problema.
Se lo podían permitir.
Las economías crecían tanto que la deuda
externa no suponía ningún peso.
En términos relativos, para muchos países,
su situación aparentemente, incluso mejoró.
Pero claro, con el impacto de la pandemia
ese escenario se dio la vuelta por completo
de la noche a la mañana.
(De repente África se enfrentó a su primera
recesión desde comienzos del nuevo siglo,
la pobreza comenzó a repuntar y muchos gobiernos
comenzaron a tener serios problemas para hacer
frente a los pagos de la deuda.
Y no solo eso, la propia pandemia hizo crecer
el gasto al tiempo que redujo los ingresos,
lo que multiplicó las necesidades financieras
de muchos estados, algo que hizo que la deuda
pública, tal y como podéis ver en pantalla,
repuntara con fuerza.)
Para colmo, las agencias de calificación
redujeron la calificación crediticia de un
montón de países, hasta el punto de que
hoy el 93% de los gobiernos africanos evaluados
por estas agencias se encuentran por debajo
del grado de inversión.
Es decir, su deuda es considerada como bonos
basura.
Lo que significa mucho menos dinero disponible
y dinero mucho más caro.
Amigos, hablamos de un problema de deuda,
un problema que podría llegado el caso derivar
en toda una crisis financiera y económica.
Países tan prósperos durante las últimas
décadas como Kenia, Etiopía o Camerún han
empezado a tener algunos problemas.
Y amigos aquí han saltado todas las alarmas
Primero por el riesgo de que se desaten nuevas
crisis humanitarias en África, y segundo
por el riesgo geopolítico que conlleva.
Porque, si hablamos de deuda y África tenemos
que hablar necesariamente de China.
Por ejemplo, el propio gobierno de los Estados
Unidos, en tiempos de la Administración Trump,
llegó a denunciar el uso perverso por parte
de la República Popular China de la conocida
como “diplomacia de la trampa de la deuda”.
Ahora bien, ¿qué hay de verdad en todo esto?
¿Hasta dónde llegan las intenciones de China?
¿De qué demonios está hablando el gobierno
de Estados Unidos?
Atentos.
[Stop, un momento antes de continuar.
¿Habéis escuchado hablar de la carne cultivada
en laboratorios?
¿De la tecnología del ARN mensajero de los
viajes espaciales?
Queridos amigos, amigas nuestro mundo está
cambiando a toda velocidad.
Y la pregunta es: ¿Qué significa esto para
los inversores?
Si quieres saber más sobre todos estos temas
no te pierdas “¿Cómo invertir en el futuro?,
el último vídeo de “Si lo Hubiera Sabido”,
el canal de actualidad financiera de Mutuactivos.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción.]
Pero...
Dicho esto, continuemos con África, China
y la llamada trampa de la deuda.
Atentos.
(LA COMPRA CHINA DE ÁFRICA)
Desde que Xi Jinping llegó al poder, África
ha cobrado cada vez más y más peso en la
diplomacia china.
Tan solo como presidente del gigante asiático,
además de impulsar foros y espacios de reunión,
el líder chino ha realizado 4 giras por el
continente.
Así que podemos decir que la presencia de
Xi Jinping en África ha sido mucho mayor
que la de cualquier otro gran líder internacional.
Y eso, eso se nota.
La política china ha seguido los pasos de
los crecientes lazos económicos que unen
a China con África… O quizás ha sido la
economía quién ha seguido a la política…
¿Qué fue antes, el huevo o la gallina?
El caso, amigos, es que desde el año 2000
el comercio de China con África se ha incrementado
en más del 2000%, hasta superar los 200 mil
millones de dólares en 2019.
Y eso no es todo.
Si en 2006 había 800 empresas estatales chinas
operando en el continente africano, hoy son
más de 10.000 las empresas públicas y privadas
que están presentes, lo que ha hecho que
China se convierta también, junto a Reino
Unido y Francia, en el mayor inversor en la
región.
El 40% del mercado de las infraestructuras,
un porcentaje de la actividad minera y más
del 12% de toda la producción industrial
de África está ya en manos de empresas chinas.
(Empresas como Transsion, el fabricante de
móviles con sede en Shenzhen que lidera el
mercado africano y que opera fábricas locales.
Fábricas como la que en 2011 abrió en Addis
Abeba, la capital de Etiopía, en la que fabrica
más de 1 millón de terminales móviles cada
año.)
Hablamos de una exposición que no para de
crecer.
Apuestas como por ejemplo, la que el 21 de
septiembre de 2021 presentó el propio embajador
chino en Nigeria, cuándo anunció que se
estaba ultimando el desembarco por la puerta
grande de alguno de los bancos más grandes
de China en el país africano.
("China ha elegido Nigeria por una razón
específica.
El petróleo.
Nigeria, como estado miembro de la OPEP, registra
sus ventas de petróleo en dólares.
Esta medida tiene el objetivo de persuadir
al sector energético de Nigeria para que
acepte pagos en yuanes por su petróleo".
Arthur Dong, profesor de estrategia y economía
de la Universidad de Georgetown)
Pero, un momento, porque si algo ha destacado
durante los últimos años, eso ha sido precisamente
la deuda.
Queridos amigos, amigas, China se ha convertido
en el mayor prestamista extranjero de toda
África.
Según la iniciativa África-China de la Universidad
Johns Hopkings, tan solo los préstamos oficiales
del gobierno y las grandes empresas públicas
de China sumaron más de 150 mil millones
de dólares entre los años 2000 y 2018.
Por ejemplo, durante las últimas dos décadas
China ha financiado 1 de cada 5 proyectos
de infraestructuras en el continente.
Muchos de estos préstamos, cuyas cláusulas
y condiciones concretas son secretas por exigencia
de Pekín, incluyen según parece activos
estratégicos soberanos como garantía o,
incluso, el pago con materias primas.
Este podría ser por ejemplo el caso de Angola,
el país que, con mucha diferencia, más préstamos
ha recibido de China y cuya devolución se
estaría realizando en gran medida con barriles
de petróleo.
Algo que tal y como veremos puede ser uno
de los grandes objetivos de la potencia asiática.
Pero sobre la deuda con China, fijaos, en
lo que decía el Ministro de finanzas de Uganda
en una carta de 2018 dirigida al Presidente
Museveni:
("Dado lo que está ocurriendo en nuestros
países pares en lo que respecta a la deuda
de China, creemos firmemente que debemos proteger
nuestros activos de una posible incautación.
Matia Kasaija, Ministro de Finanzas de Uganda
en 2018)
Así que teniendo todo esto en cuanto, creo
que hay unas cuántas preguntas que debemos
hacernos:
¿Qué busca exactamente China en África?
¿Existe la trampa de la deuda?
¿Qué implicaciones tiene para el continente
africano todo este proceso que hemos descrito?
Atentos.
(LA TRAMPA DE LA DEUDA)
La pregunta, la gran pregunta que creo todos
podemos hacernos es:
¿Qué busca China?
¿Qué precio exige realmente a cambio de
su apoyo financiero?
Y no, no me estoy refiriendo al tipo de interés.
En 2017, la Administración Trump comenzó
a poner sobre la mesa la idea de la Trampa
de la deuda.
Según este planteamiento, el gobierno chino
estaría básicamente promoviendo la entrega
de préstamos oficiales a países en vías
de desarrollo con el objetivo esencial de
endeudarlos hasta el cuello para así tenerlos
controlados y poder sacar tajada, es decir
lograr concesiones.
Así que para ver si esto tiene o no sentido,
si os parece vamos a cambiar ligeramente la
pregunta: De estar en lo cierto, ¿Qué beneficios
podría obtener exactamente China?
Vale, creo que el primero de todos ellos es
muy evidente.
China devora materias primas y si algo tiene
África, eso son precisamente recursos naturales.
(Más de una tercera parte de todo el petróleo
que importa o el 20% del algodón que consume
la industria textil china procede de África.
Y todo eso por no hablar de recursos como
el manganeso, esencial para la producción
de acero, o el coltán, vital para la industria
electrónica y cuyas mayores reservas se encuentran,
precisamente, en este continente.
Y estos son solo 4 ejemplos de una larga lista
que podríamos poner sobre la mesa.
)
De esta forma, los préstamos podrían tener
una doble función: por un lado construir
las infraestructuras que China necesita para
poder explotar esos recursos; por otro tener
“pillados” a los gobiernos para controlar
esos recursos.
Pero más allá de otra cuestión, si algo
ha destacado últimamente es el rédito político.
Sí, sí, lo habéis escuchado.
El uso político de la deuda a cambio de una
mejora de las condiciones o de una extensión
de los plazos de pago.
Fijaos.
(En 2020, de los 53 países que firmaron una
declaración de apoyo a China en el Consejo
de Derechos Humanos de la ONU tras la aprobación
de la Ley de Seguridad Nacional en Hong Kong,
25 eran africanos.
Y otros 3 grandes países: Nigeria, Sudáfrica
y Kenia aunque no la secundaron tampoco se
sumaron a las críticas contra Pekín.
Y exactamente lo mismo ocurrió con las denuncias
contra la persecución a los uigures y otras
minorías étnicas.
Muchos países africanos han apoyado a China
en los organismos internacionales.
Asimismo, por otro lado, los votos de los
países africanos también están respaldando
la elección de representantes chinos para
dirigir importantes instituciones internacionales,
como es el caso de la Organización de las
Naciones Unidas para la Alimentación y la
Agricultura, dirigida desde 2019 por un representante
del gobierno chino gracias en buena medida
a los votos africanos.)
M Vale, es evidente que todo está ocurriendo.
La deuda concedida a los gobiernos africanos
le da a Pekín una enorme ventaja a la hora
de negociar.
Pero, ¿es esta toda la historia?
África necesita capital, necesita infraestructuras,
necesita inversiones.
Y ahí China podría estar jugando un papel
importante.
Porque la pregunta qué podemos hacernos es,
¿Ha mejorado o no ha mejorado África durante
las últimas dos décadas?
("No creo que haya un plan deliberado por
parte de China para endeudar a ningún país.
Creo que China está cumpliendo un papel muy
importante, que es en términos de apoyo a
la infraestructura".
Akinwumi Adesina, Presidente del Banco Africano
de Desarrollo)
Además, por mucho que hablemos de la trampa
de la deuda y por mucho que nos digan desde
Washington no podemos obviar una realidad:
la República Popular China se ha convertido
en el mayor prestamista pero ni mucho menos
en el único.
( China controla,aproximadamente, en torno
al 25% de la deuda externa de África, lo
cual es mucho, sí, pero también quiere decir
que el 75% restante está en manos de otros
países u organismos.
Tan solo el Banco Mundial y el FMI tienen
casi tanto peso en la deuda de África como
China.
Solo Zambia, Yibuti y la República Democrática
del Congo tienen la mayor parte de su deuda
en manos chinas)
Pero, recapitulemos: China está sacando tajada
política de sus crecientes relaciones con
África, pero aparentemente África necesita
las inversiones chinas.
Sin embargo, un momento, amigos, porque hay
otro factor a tener en cuenta.
[No todo es tan sencillo]
China financia lo que le da gana, lo que está
muy bien, pero tenemos que tenerlo claro.
[China financia lo que le da la gana.].
Y, ¿Sabéis qué?
Quizás el problema está en que muchos de
los proyectos impulsados no tengan sentido
económico.
Qué es exactamente lo que ha ocurrido en
la misma China.
Por ejemplo, un estudio de la Universidad
de Oxford en 2016 determinó que más de la
mitad de todos los proyectos de infraestructuras
realizados en China durante los últimos 30
años han tenido un rendimiento por los suelos.
Según este estudio solo el 28% de los proyectos
podían ser considerados económicamente interesantes.
En otras palabras, ¿Y si el modelo chino
no funciona?
El gobierno chino genera los suficientes recursos
como para derrochar en infraestructuras sobredimensionadas
o innecesarias.
Pero ese no es el caso de los gobiernos africanos.
Quizás eso sí sea una consecuencia no buscada
de la deuda china.
Mucha ojito con esta cuestión.
Si los proyectos tienen pobres rendimientos
económicos, quieren decir que pueden no generar
lo suficiente como para devolver la deuda.
Claro que no tiene porqué ser así.
África necesita inversiones y nadie hubiera
podido esperar el impacto del coronavirus.
Por supuesto queda claro que la Inversión
Extranjera Directa es mejor que la mera financiación
y también está claro que Pekín utilizará
todos los instrumentos a su alcance para obtener
ventajas políticas, aunque ello suponga hacer
tratos con líderes corruptos y firmar préstamos
para fines cuestionables.
Pero, amigos, si hay algún responsable en
última instancia esos son los líderes africanos.
En cualquier caso, seamos optimistas, el capital
construido prevalece, China está muy interesada
en que África prospere y ahora todo apunta
a que entramos en un ciclo de precios de las
materias primas al alza.
Un ciclo que puede darle al continente africano
los recursos que necesita para superar el
golpe de la pandemia y volver a la senda de
crecimiento que ha mantenido durante los últimos
20 años.
No sé, personalmente, ¿qué queréis que
os diga?
Puede que exista la diplomacia de la deuda…
Pero creo que no conviene exagerar ni ver
fantasmas por todas las esquinas.
Si preocupa la presencia china en África
lo que tendrán que hacer los gobiernos occidentales
es buscar las fórmulas para mejorar la inversión
en este continente y la integración de los
países africanos en la economía mundial.
Es sólo una opinión, mi opinión.
Ahora turno para ti: ¿Crees que China realmente
está empleando la deuda estrictamente como
arma política?
¿Qué crees que tienen que hacer las potencias
occidentales?
¿Deberían combatir, contrarrestar la creciente
influencia china en Africa?
Déjanos tu respuesta por aquí abajo en los
comentarios.
Y como siempre si este vídeo te ha resultado
interesante no olvides darle a like.
Muchísimas gracias a todos los patreons que
nos apoyáis y habéis hecho posible este
vídeo.
Un abrazo y hasta la próxima.